Oprah Winfrey she has a recurring role
on the own series greenlease and our
Brooke Anderson was first on the set as
they raised a bar for his very saucy
season - you've got the infidelity the
greed the adultery the betrayal the
sinning one of the things that informs
me so much is all of those years of
doing the Oprah show it was like living
in a life's classroom if a man hits you
once he will hit you again
not everybody can get over an affair so
being able to take some of those
dysfunctional stories that people
actually shared with me in our audience
and be able to incorporate them into the
lives of our characters is fantastic
she's using 25 years of Oprah shows to
help with storylines but the best part
about being boss you got to tell
everybody what to do singing about my my
own character Mavis I had said to the
writers Mavis needed to shake her wig
out of it and whoa shakin going on you
going down did you work with the stylist
and everybody to get the hair and the
makeup and the Wardrobe I wanted a real
fro like a frou-frou like I used to wear
and the fro was too big
we're always like we can't see around
the throw and I didn't want to have a
low for us so we let that go and just
did the sort of curly wiry thing
Brooke met Oprah on the Atlanta set of
Greenleaf as they begin shooting season
number two but Leigh do admit she's
still recovering from this scene with
her on-screen sister Lynn Whitfield in
the dramatic finale
Oprah came unhinged invite is to blame
for whatever it is you came down here to
[ __ ] to me about it's you because you
knew I could see the simmering rage in
your eyes as you were playing that it
was explosive I am NOT gonna
you'll stick out you brought this on
yourself that scene wasn't written when
I came to set that day somebody write me
a scene right now it work so that they
can go at it and I will tell you for me
I don't carry a lot of anger I just
don't I just don't I don't even I don't
even have it buried so I have to dig so
deep bring it up to bring it up that on
the day we did that scene I had such a
migraine headache from digging this is
what I learned but what I learned is
o-m-g there are people walking around he
was feeling this all the time
Mike's a nothing oh my god don't be sick
it's unhealthy
they must be sent why we look to you for
your wisdom will you please run for
president one day that will never happen
to me that is the one thing I can say
will never happen to me everybody can
take a deep breath